nearly three billion people around the
world are expected to tune in to watch
tomorrow's royal wedding here in Windsor
more than 100,000 people will gather in
the streets hoping to catch a glimpse of
Prince Harry and Meghan Markel normally
the population is about thirty two
thousand so imagine how many people are
gonna be here tomorrow among them will
be for women who first met at Tennessee
State University more than thirty years
ago they have traveled all over the
world together and they made this trip
to England to be part of this
once-in-a-lifetime event
Charlie Daggett is here in Windsor with
more on their story Charlie good morning
I am Charlie d'Agata here in Windsor and
these are my new friends melissa Smith
Birmingham Alabama we followed them all
the way from the United States here's
his story we're gonna chat in just a
second I just can't wait to just be
there
Debbie Howard and Melanie smooth were on
board with the couple long before they
were on board the plane to London
they're young they're hip they're cool
he's marrying an American girl at the
hotel a bit of bubbly to kick off the
festivities where conversation moved on
to fashion and fascinators but yet not
like any other royal wedding
what will Megan an American bride in the
Royal Court where I think that she's
gonna do something with her hair up and
I think she was gonna have a straight
line with a little bit of lace I wonder
if she'll wear something of Diana's I
bet you so it was hope she looks like a
princess and as Diana shook up the
monarchy they wonder what kind of impact
Megan Markel a biracial American actress
will have on the British royal family
she came along she got Queen Elizabeth
to change her tune on a few things I
think their love signifies diversity and
I think that this world this world is
going to by him choosing his bride and
that she is african-american that just
makes it all the best she got the Prince
yeah like what woman would not fall in
love with that now these ladies travel
all over the world what made you decide
that you had to make it here for this
one why Meg Megan Markell what is it
about that just made it overwhelming for
us to have to come here and there was
never questioned you all decided whose
idea was it and everybody else said and
you're gonna watch it front-row seats
okay that's what we got here Gil back to
you
Charlie Thank You Tiffany Margaux Debbie
and Melanie love those girls thanks a
lot charlie